debate club and this guy is uh
he's got an appropriate one what up
y'all it's your boy
fro bob long pants out here with a
debate club
for y'all boys cause i seen the post i
seen i needed some help
so i got a debate club for y'all bro
robot since the new year is coming up
you feel me
what would y'all
what would y'all rather do go out to the
clubs into the bars and all that from
new year's
or do like a little kickback function
kind of
deal at the crib with some friends and
you know
y'all just drink do that
friends bro you better get some tips out
there dogs i need to know
tits in your face for the new year's
yeah listen what i would do
is funny all right yes sir yes sir
yes sir hey [ __ ] favorite look
i'm high i'm smoking marijuana okay he's
high on that kush man he's hopped up
like it's all over we're in la son it's
everywhere out here
bro what i would say what i would do for
new year's
i'd go to palm beach improv that's what
i would do because i'll be in that [ __ ]
but if i'm not do if i'm not working i'm
at home bro
and i'm not even awake when that ball
[ __ ] drops i can't tell you the last
time i was
awake when that probably when we did the
[ __ ] comedy store thing
other than that dude i'm asleep by 10
bro i don't give a
[ __ ] about that ball dropping everyone
watches anderson cooper bring you into
the
[ __ ] new year i'm that's i'm not
about that life people blowing
rvs up and [ __ ] i'm trying to be my
undies watching reruns the first 48.
oh yeah it's good at all i hate to say
how it ends but a black guy kills
everybody uh
they're always in oklahoma it's always
the worst
it's like something the guy never know
what why'd you do it scoops and the
guy's like oh no man
and they're always ratting on each other
you realize cops can't do [ __ ] without
snitches you realize they
they're not very good at their job they
have no evidence no fingerprints
it's always snitches that solve the case
it really
is every episode fingerprints isn't even
a thing anymore no
every episode literally if they sing or
see fingerprints they will wash them off
of the crime scene yeah because they
know someone's gonna snitch
that's crazy man it's just different man
it's just yeah why'd you do it scoops i
don't know
what you doing for new year steel uh
well look first of all i want to say
this man thanks for the submission young
brother and i know it's
you know and i'm gonna go out on a limb
a short limb and say this guy's
obviously a mixed gentleman
and that's really where it is the power
today is really with the mixed gentleman
you know you see
with patrick mahomes with um
who else man
yeah the weekend it's everywhere so what
i'm saying is this man uh
i don't think going out to a club then
you first of all you got to go to the
club it's going to be loud the music
hasn't even been that great this year
so you have to be listening all of that
[ __ ] then you got to convince
a woman if you like women to come back
to your house or you know
covet pad you gotta it's just too much
man
so i think you yeah you do a small get
together
maybe smoke a little bit of the lamb's
wool baby you know what i'm saying that
freaking
the tuft of the lord baby that dawn
and then yeah man and just chill out man
jerk off or hug somebody and jerk off
bro
yeah but don't bring the new years in
crying
no no no no which gets me back to you
what are you doing for new year's
you really skirted that question yeah i
actually scheduled my last cry session
of the year is
december 29th smart man
um what am i doing i don't know man
sounds like you i haven't thought of
anything yeah sounds like you have no
plans
i have no plans i'll probably see if
anybody's having a party or something
but i don't know anybody that is so
i will probably just relax and get a
nice pizza ooh
a nice maybe cheese pizza to yourself
yeah dude get a cheese pizza pumpkin
style
make some bread sticks maybe make 10
breadsticks and break one of them in
half in honor of my father [ __ ] yeah
honor my dad too man go and dip that
[ __ ] in that sauce for me
oh yeah i will
[Music]
is